we had a very intensive
general council today, the last
regular scheduled and the
austrian presidency
, at the end we also handed over the
baton to the
roman presidency, but
maybe in order
we started with a very intensive
exchange on the current status of the
negotiations for several years
financial framework in general, it has also been
recognized that we and the
austrian presidency have made good
progress here and that we de facto have
a finished negotiating box on the
table, and that will also be
part of the issue at the european council of heads of state
and government at the end of the week, of
course we have  we also
prepared this accordingly and
discussed the possible conclusions,
which we also did very intensively
, to exchange views on the aspect
of subsidiarity, you know, in austria we have
a spherical conference on
this subject in bregenz with a
dedicated  a statement from bregenz was also
noted here by the general public
that is a good basis is also for
the preparations for the meeting
next year in romania where it is also about
the future of the european union
we also have two
articles seven procedures in the afternoon
on the agenda in poland there was a
second herring and the general council
continue to deal with this issue
as well as discuss procedures
and hungary where they gave a first exchange